[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled the evolving therapeutic
potential and regulation of cbd this
webinar is a part of the fifth annual
2022 cannabis sciences virtual event i'm
antonina salcido of labroots and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
now let's get started
before we begin i'd just like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to first
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation
you can find that live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the help desk button located at
the bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr jeffrey
chen ceo and co-founder of radical
science
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen dr chen you may now
begin your presentation
all right well thank you for having me
it's a pleasure to be here
a lot of stuff we're going to cover
today and i'll leave plenty of time at
the end for q a
a bit about myself i you know i'm
trained as a physician but i've always
been more on the
business and entrepreneurial side of
things after medical school actually
started ucla's cannabis research program
and ran that for a number of years
and left left that about a year and a
half ago to start radical science and we
run clinical trials
for health and wellness products
and we do them at a tremendous
improvement in cost and speed
so
diving into the agenda today so first
we'll talk about therapeutic potential
of cbd mainly focusing on what we have
from human clinical trial data but also
touch briefly on
some what the animal data shows but with
a strong caveat there we'll talk about
the regulatory landscape of what's
happening with cbd some of the things
that the fda is finding when they do
these tests of cbd products
and lastly we'll talk about
the some of the preliminary results from
the aces study which was the largest cbd
trial ever done in history and we'll see
some of the interesting kind of signals
that are bubbling up from that
so
very briefly on this slide i just wanted
to
uh
oh there we go so just very briefly you
know cannabis has
well over 100 cannabinoids you know thc
cbd they tend to be the most abundant in
the strains that are grown today
and we have the most knowledge of them
they've been the most well studied and
very briefly you know thc's the primary
intoxicating ingredient in cannabis cbd
is non-intoxicating notice i didn't use
the word psychoactive because cbd does
impact the central nervous system so it
is psychoactive it's just not
intoxicating
thc has addictive properties independent
properties cbd does not and in fact cbd
might even have some you know anti
addictive properties
uh thc can cause motor impairments
worried about stone driving cbd does no
such thing
and this can give you the munchies cbd
has no
increase in appetite effects
so even though they're both cannabinoids
very different effects they present and
in terms of mechanism of action you know
thc has binding affinity at our
cannabinoid receptors
which are part of our endocannabinoid
system you can google more about that
cbd on the other hand doesn't seem to
have much of effect at the cannabinoid
receptors in our body they work through
other
receptors ppar receptors serotonin
receptors and also they might seem to
maybe boost
your levels of endocannabinoids so the
cannabinoids that your body naturally
produces
but there's still a lot we don't know
about how cbd actually impacts our
bodies
now if we're looking at human clinical
trial data on cbd you can break down
things into what we know a lot of what
we know a little bit about of and what
we know pretty much nothing about
and so starting with uh this is a
sequence that's interesting hold on
there we go
so starting with what we know a lot
about we have a lot a lot of rigorous
clinical trial data
on the
benefits of cbd for epilepsy in
particular these pediatric forms of
epilepsy in fact that's what cbd is fda
approved for
we have a little bit of information that
cbd can have anti-addictive properties
in particular with individuals who
are
have a dependency to opioids or have
cravings for opioids there's a little
bit of clinical trial data that cbd can
actually help with schizophrenics
actually reducing their symptoms and
psychosis
and it seems to have a beneficial impact
on anxiety and in particular social
anxiety
and there's pretty much
little to no
human data on how cbd can be used to
treat pain or to treat insomnia and the
reason and you know and much much more
right and the reason i bring this up is
you hear people anecdotally
talk about all the benefits of cbd but
when you look at the actual rigorous
clinical trial data
a vast majority of things that people
talk about or that companies are selling
products to or the consumers using these
products for aren't really grounded in
clinical trial data
now when we look at the animal data on
actually one one thing i also want to
mention um
on cbd in terms of the side effects of
cbd you know cbd has a has a good safety
profile but there are still side effects
so some of the most common side effects
include lethargy and
digestive issues sometimes diarrhea
things like that and also there's a
concern from the fda that cbd might
elevate your liver enzymes it might be
causing
some sort of malfunction of liver and
i'll talk a little bit more about that
later
but we definitely need more data on that
that's some of the reasons why
the fda is doesn't have a favorable
position on cbd
now when looking at animal data on cbd
we see that it has analgesic properties
so again in rat studies anti-pain
properties again we haven't really fully
studied that in humans
has sleep modulating effects and again
very
we don't really have clinical trial data
on cbd for that
we have we know that cbd is antioxidant
properties
has anti-inflammatory properties
actually anti-tumor effects either
slowing the growth of cancer
actively shrinking cancer working
synergistically
with other
chemotherapeutic agents to inhibit and
kill cancer cells
and it's also neuro protected so
preserving
neuronal function and viability in life
of stresses whether it's ischemic stress
lacks of oxygen
all the way to
mouse models of dementia
of alzheimer's you actually see that
you're able to prevent and
mitigate those effects in mice who are
otherwise predetermined to have
alzheimer's through genetic
predisposition
so some pretty fascinating things in the
animal data again huge caveat you know
last time i checked we're not rats so
it's we need more human clinical trials
to really flush these areas out
now turning our attention to the
regulations so for those who aren't
familiar in 2018
the usda farm bill was passed and within
it there was a provision that
said hey we're gonna we're gonna define
this thing called hemp and hemp is gonna
be anything from the cannabis species
that has less than 0.3 thc and for
comparison cannabis sold in these state
legal dispensaries whether for adult use
or medical purposes you tend to see 10
15 20 25 30
thc so we're talking you know one to two
orders of magnitude less thc in hemp
and the farm bill basically said hemp is
now an agricultural product it is not a
controlled substance so that's what
opened the floodgates to both hemp
cultivation but also uh the explosion
you see in cbd commerce
prior to that cbd was
theoretically a controlled substance so
it was difficult
to engage in commerce with it
now that same year the fda actually
approved the first ever the first and
only drug in america that contains cbd
it's called epidialex
it's approved for pediatric epilepsy and
it's basically pure cbd dissolved in
sesame oil
now this had profound
implications for the
dietary supplement non-prescription
usage of cbd
and that's when we get to this notion of
the drug
preclusion
and so
the drug preclusion is this fda
regulation
that says when it comes to
things that can be sold as a dietary
supplement
but also somehow end up being a
prescription drug
depending on which came first
will impact
how it can be sold so if the
pharmaceutical drug
got to basically an investigational new
drug status before that same compound
was sold as a supplement it can never be
sold as a supplement
and their rationale for creating this
regulation it's not a new regulation the
rationale was you know if a pharma
company is going to invest
a lot of time and money into bringing a
product through the fda
and that product maybe say is naturally
occurring it could also be sold as a
supplement the pharma company needs
assurances that if they were to put all
this time and effort in you're not just
going to have a thousand companies
selling it as a supplement and writing
the research writing the validation that
the pharma company
generated
now if that same product was already
being sold as a supplement and then a
pharma company took it through the fda
both are allowed to be
sold so it depends on which came first
and so
right now the fda's stance is that
epidialex was an investigational drug
well before 2014
and cbd wasn't really marketed or sold
as a supplement
uh any earlier than that so the fda will
cite this drug preclusion
rule as to why
cbd can't be sold as a supplement it is
and forever will be a drug that requires
fda approval
so fda has been sending lots of warning
letters to brands and companies selling
cbd
off
the warning letters are talking about
that these are unapproved
new drugs that can't be sold like this
the warning letters also
have described
often these products are making disease
claims so the warning letters are often
centered around that
the warning letters also will discuss
some of the potential side effects that
the fda is concerned about i mentioned
some of that earlier some of the side
effects but the main side effect that
the fda is concerned about is this issue
of
liver
dysfunction
and
almost all of that data or concern comes
from the fda trials of epidialex
for pediatric epilepsy
and in those trials those study
participants were already quite sick
these are kids who are having dozens
maybe hundreds of seizures a day they
were already on a slew of other
medications
anti-epileptic drugs for example that
have a
a known
impact detrimental impact on the liver
and they were using doses of cbd that
were extraordinarily high sometimes in
excess of a thousand
milligrams a day and for a reference
your average cbd product on the market
maybe has a serving size of
25 milligrams
of cbd
and so
counter arguments against the fda's
concern
is that the liver safety issue was
brought about in a study population that
looks nothing like the average american
taking these products
and stemmed from a dosage of cbd that
looks nothing like the dosages of cbd
found in these commercial products
another issue that the fda is concerned
about is the mislabeling of cbd products
they tested well over 100 products and
they found that
less than half
actually had
cbd content that was within a certain
margin of error to what was actually on
the label
so for all these reasons the the fda has
had a very chilly attitude
towards cbd
and right now the regulations
are kind of stuck in a quagmire you know
you have
thousands of cbd brands out there you
have tens of millions of americans using
cbd
some retailers carry cbd some retailers
won't
the fda continues to say
that
these shouldn't be sold these can't be
sold enforcement hasn't been very strict
uh
and so it's it's unfortunately
uh it's a quagmire to say the least
okay
now shifting gears a little bit i'm
going to talk about
a study called aces and it stands for
advancing cbd education and science and
it was a study that was recently
completed and it was the largest cbd
clinical trial ever done in history and
involved several thousand individuals
and it was actually run by my company
radical science um so i'll talk a bit
more about how we ran the study we'll go
through some of the results um and some
of the
interesting findings and how they might
add to the scientific literature
so the first thing is the aces research
team was actually a collaboration
between my company radical science many
of our scientists as well as
collaborators from various
universities
uh and researchers in general so it was
a whole team
effort and we're currently working on
the manuscript which we will be
submitting for peer review publication
within the next you know month or so
and so this is a
what was really nice is a lot of
what we tried to do with aces wasn't
really possible
at the university level
and by that i mean had i tried to run
the same study while i was running
ucla's cannabis research program it
wouldn't have worked for several reasons
that we can talk about so it was nice
that we were able to do it independent
of the universities but still get input
from various
uh faculty and individuals that are
affiliated uh with universities
so what was really interesting about
the way we ran this study
it was that it was completely virtual
so we didn't involve clinical trial
sites there were no clinical assessments
it involved participants from all 50
states a significant amount of which
were lived in rural communities which
are traditionally excluded from clinical
trials
the studies were conducted virtually
the products arrived direct to consumer
they were just shipped in the mail
consumers participated and gave data
directly to us via their email and
mobile devices
and we recruited people virtually too
whereas in a typical trial you have say
a hospital involved
they slowly recruit through the patients
that come through the hospital
once they're recruited into the study
they go to the hospital to get the
product they go to the hospital to give
data et cetera all these things that
dramatically increase the cost the time
the complexity as well as the burden
on the participants and that's why you
often see lots of communities
underrepresented in physical trials this
is also a very large scale study again
with 3 000 people involved the next
largest
cbd study prior to this maybe had a few
hundred people so it was an order of
magnitude larger
and really building in that intentional
heterogeneity in the study population
again geography
demographics etc whereas
clinical trials often result in very
homogeneous study populations and also
we kept the inclusion exclusion criteria
very broad
to be able to have a large
diverse
study population come in
as far as the study design goes the
study ran for four weeks so individuals
received product they used it for four
weeks and we collected health outcome
data for four weeks
it was an open label study which means
the participants knew
which of the 13 products they had
received
and we got irb approval for the study as
well
so the way this worked is
people in the study were randomized to
one of 13 products or they were put on a
waitlist control
and the weightless control meant that
they were going to receive product but
they weren't going to get it till the
study ended
so while they were in the study they
weren't taking any product but we were
still tracking their health outcomes
and
what is nice about that control is it
allows us to do two things it allows us
one to observe what's the natural
resolution
of someone that has
symptoms of pain or sleep or anxiety so
we know the natural course without any
treatment
and that control group also lets us
account for macro
factors so for instance
if you were in
eastern europe right now with a war
going on
you might everyone's anxiety might go
through the roof everyone might have
disturbed sleep and so by looking at the
control group we can kind of understand
control for macro conditions that might
be impacting the health outcomes we
observe
so nearly three thousand participants
were recruited to be eligible you had to
have
reporting symptoms of anxiety a sleep
issue or chronic pain
and they were randomized to receive one
of 13 products or to be in the waitlist
control
and the main objectives we were looking
at were actually
well-being which is a very holistic
encompassing measure
and the secondary objectives we were
looking at were change in pain sleep
disturbance and anxiety compared to the
control group
the health outcome measures we looked at
we're all using validated outcome
measures what's nice about these it's
you're not simply just saying you know
on a scale of one to five how do you
feel
these are
measures that have been tested in
countless prior trials they've been
demonstrated to accurately track these
conditions they've been demonstrated to
be sensitive to change they've been
demonstrated to
have external validity as well and also
with these measures they allow us to
benchmark to the prior literature so we
know
for instance on the promise sleep
disturbance scale when that score
changes x amount we know is that a
meaningful change or is that maybe just
noise because these measures have been
validated in so many prior clinical
trials we know it's meaningful changes
in these measures and we also looked at
side effects as well
looking at the study products if you if
you google aces you can see the 13
brands who were involved i didn't list
them here
but you can see that
we had a wide diversity of product
attributes and that was a goal of aces
as well so we had
capsules and tablets and tinctures and
soft gels and gummies and
oral sprays
they had different dosages
different spectrum as well you know full
spectrum meaning that it is a
relatively
unprocessed extract
of hemp
and contains some
legal limit of thc
then you have broad spectrum which
typically refers to a full spectrum
product where the thc has been removed
to have effectively zero thc as opposed
to full spectrum which has a little thc
and then you might often will hear
isolate isolate just means pure
cbd
so
you know broad spectrum and full
spectrum might have other cannabinoids
and tiny amounts they might have other
phytocompounds from the hemp plant in
tiny amounts whereas isolates just pure
cbd
so again we had broad isolate and full
spectrum products
as well and the cbd dosage per serving
range from
single digits all the way to 50 to 100
milligrams a serving
so again we had people participating
from all 50 states although most of the
participants came from california texas
and florida which is not surprising
those are the three largest states in
our country
one
interesting thing is you know
females have traditionally been
underrepresented in clinical trials in
fact there was a very long period of
time where females were not allowed to
be in clinical trials and so when we
went to recruit we specifically
made sure to
recruit heavily through channels that we
know would reach a lot of women and in
some ways we succeeded but in other ways
we
recruited we didn't we we overshot
having a equal
gender ratio so we were aiming to have
equal female male participation we ended
up having you know over 90
of the participants being female now if
you look at the demographics of cbd
users and the demographics of people who
purchase supplements for the household
it skews female
but we weren't expecting this uh and
since then we've corrected our
recruitment measures so our studies are
all now roughly even male and female
ratios
in terms of their experience with cbd
about a third had never tried it and
nearly two-thirds had only tried it a
few times but we did exclude anyone who
reported active current regular use of
cbd
now looking at some of the outcome
measures
so
this first graph on your left
is looking at the change in their
well-being score
the blue line are the 13 different
products that people could have been
randomized to
the yellow line is the control group so
again you look at the control group and
it looks like well-being stays about the
same throughout the course of the four
weeks whereas in the product group you
had significant improvements in their
well-being score
when it came to their anxiety score
again you saw that the control group had
about the same maybe a slight decline in
their anxiety over the four weeks
without any treatment whereas the
product groups had significant declines
in their anxiety and notice that that
big inflection point
happens usually within the first week
and then it continues to improve but at
a at
a
lighter slope so we did see that
consistently across all these symptoms
was that the most improvements were seen
in the first week then you had a little
more gradual improvements all the way to
the end of the study
some of the things you can see for sleep
disturbance you know the control group
improved a little bit on their own
you had significant improvements in the
product group same thing goes for pain
on the right hand side
as well
so those are kind of the high level
visuals via charts but diving into the
actual results like we said we saw the
largest improvements were observed in
the first week of the product
when it came to well-being
there was a
70 on average a 71 improvement that the
product groups
experienced
when it came to anxiety
63 of participants experienced a
clinically meaningful
improvement again that's the beauty of
using these validated outcome measures
we know what a change in these outcome
measures
represents was it again a minor
difference or was it clinically
meaningful clinically meaningful being
that it is a
palpable and distinct improvement to
their symptoms and to their quality of
life
and when it came to sleep a slightly
smaller number 61 percent of
the people who receive products
as opposed to the control group
experienced a clinically meaningful
improvement and then pain you had a
lower
uh
a percentage of people who experienced
an improvement but still 47
had a clinically meaningful
improvement so you're seeing you know
half to well over half of individuals
who received a cbd product
actually experiencing clinically
meaningful improvement within four weeks
and large improvements within the first
week so what what this is telling you is
that
the folks who are
walking into a store
and buying a cbd product
most of them
for these symptoms are experiencing a
significant improvement in the symptoms
into their
quality of life and that's probably why
no surprise that despite
the fda's warnings despite major
retailers not caring cbd you have
tens of tens of tens of millions of
americans
who are using cbd and i believe up to a
third if not more of all americans have
tried
cbd at some point
now we looked at the data a different
way and we were trying to figure out was
there any characteristic about an
individual that would predict
their
likelihood of experiencing a positive
outcome
and we didn't find any so we we looked
at the data set separating males and
females we looked at the data sets
separating
the
naive versus experienced users we looked
at the data sets separating different
age groups and we could find no
differences none of these were
predictors
of a
likelihood of positive response to cbd
now when it came to side effects
there was on average about 10
of participants who received one of the
products reported some side effects and
if you look at this chart the most
common side effects were generally
related to digestive issues
there was also some
headache being a common one but the top
at the top
four issues three were related to
digestive issues you know gas
diarrhea bloating
a lot of these products did contain
oil as the carrier so sometimes oil can
also upset the digestive tract as well
it could also have been due to
the cbd
but generally you know you can see that
side effects were relatively uncommon
and generally
mild
and again
when it came to the fda's warnings on
cbd they weren't they they weren't
other side effects that have been
reported in the literature have also
been
you know
gastrointestinal issues it's been a
major one again when it comes back to
the fda they are concerned about liver
safety liver safety liver safety liver
safety that's their biggest concern
from a safety standpoint again owing to
what we saw in those clinical trials of
those pediatric epilepsy patients using
ultra high
doses
of cbd
and
some other areas that we weren't really
assessing in our study and that no one
really knows the answer to is the impact
of cbd on the reproductive system
so
there is a theoretical
impact on say
some of the other fda's concerns are it
might impact the male
reproductive system lowering potentially
lowering rates of fertility and it's
still unknown what the impact of cbd is
on say a developing fetus
so generally the caution here
is for cbd is if you have
liver disease or if anyone's ever told
you you have an issue with your liver or
you say drink
a lot of alcohol or you're taking other
drugs that also can pose a risk to your
liver probably stay away from cbd
and if you're trying to get pregnant
probably stay away from cbd
whether you're
male or female
and
furthermore
cbd does have potential
interactions with other drugs
and so another
word of caution that i typically give is
if you're taking a prescription
medication that carries a grape fruit
warning says don't
don't eat grapefruits or drink
grapefruit juice when on this medication
you should probably also avoid cbd
and that's because cbd has and
grapefruits interact with
similar
drugs
and they can
basically depending on which drug it is
it can either boost
levels of that drug in your body or
reduce levels of that drug in your body
so if the drug at higher levels has a
toxic effect by boosting levels of that
drug in your body that's not good
also if it lowers levels of that blood
of that drug in your body but you need a
certain level for a therapeutic effect
it can diminish
the therapeutic effect as well so again
if you take drugs that carry a
grapefruit warning should probably also
avoid cbd
all right just to wrap up some of the
kind of key findings from the asus study
so
any of all you know taking any of the 13
cbd products led to significant
improvements across all of the health
outcomes
well-being sleep pain anxiety
relative to the weightless control
side effects were pretty rare and
generally mild
and when we looked at characteristics of
participants be it sex age prior cbd use
we could not find
any
predictors
any of those characteristics being
predictive
of
a positive
experience or outcome
when we looked at cbd spectrum so when
we clustered the 13 products by broad by
full or by isolate as their spectrum we
didn't see significant differences in
their health outcomes
and to our knowledge this is one of the
first if not the first trials to
actually
try to compare cbd products by spectrum
there is a
theory
and a and a belief that is discussed
widely in the cannabis space of the
so-called entourage effect
where
the whole constellation
of
phytocompounds from the cannabis plant
the terpenes the cannabinoids and in
particular thc
generate an effect that is superior to
any of the compounds
by itself
and
proponents of this theory will point to
the fact that say
marinol synthetic pure thc fda approved
since 1986.
doctors don't prescribe it much
patients don't use it much they'll
gravitate towards cannabis
even though marinol is fda approved it's
legal for usage
it's pure it's quality assured your
insurance might cover it yet people
don't really use it why is that maybe
pure thc
acts very differently than can abyss
which again has
well over 100 different phyto compounds
that have physiologic
effects so this is an area that
definitely needs
further exploration
now when we looked at
cbd per serving in our study
paradoxically
we found that
lower doses
of cbd per serving not always but often
outperformed
higher doses
for things like well-being anxiety and
pain when it came to sleep we didn't see
any dose per serving having a predictive
effect on sleep outcomes but for while
being anxiety and pain
not always but sometimes the lower doses
were actually outperforming the higher
doses and dosing is a huge
black box
question mark
for cbd no one
uh really knows
there's been so few clinical trials
exploring such a narrow dose range
for a narrow set of conditions like
earlier i mentioned schizophrenia
addiction epilepsy so no one really
knows what dose is appropriate for
pain or anxiety or insomnia
when you're talking about a fuller broad
spectrum product which
is might be principally different than a
pure cbd product that's often what was
studied not often it's pretty much what
was studied
period
in
these
prior clinical trials which is pure
pharmaceutical cpd
all right
wrapping up with some caveats here so
this was an open label study which means
the participants knew that they got cbd
it was not a placebo-controlled blinded
study
and the goal here was not actually to
disentangle the placebo effect the goal
here was to
capture in a diverse population
and using as much real-world
data approach as possible
what is happening to these tens of
millions of consumers
that are purchasing cbd every day that's
what this study was designed to mimic
because when you purchase this stuff you
know what's in it
you're using it in the comfort of your
own home
and you're using it according to how you
think you're sure there's a recommended
serving size but you end up you know
using it how you decide to use it
there was that female gender skew again
over 90 percent of people in the study
were female perhaps that has
implications on the impact on the data
and
it's actually
it's hard to draw firm conclusions
between products based on any single
characteristic
and that's because the products didn't
did not just
diff
differ from one another by one
characteristic often they were differing
by multiple characteristics so they were
different in serving size and form
factor or different in form factor and
formulation formulation being was it
broad was it full was it isolate et
cetera
so
by no means is the study
conclusive
as to what are attributes
of products
that make them more or less likely to
have positive out health outcomes
and as well as you know what are
attributes of people that make them more
or less likely to have a positive
outcome from something like cbd
and you know i
i'm not sure who this quotes attributed
to
but i always like to bring it up that
every great study warrants another four
studies
so this is
the first of many studies
that we're doing on this topic and we
hope this also inspires more research
around the world now if you try to do a
three thousand person thirteen arm
open label trial on cbd in a university
setting this
probably would never happen or it would
take you know five years or longer and
cost
millions millions and millions and
millions and millions and so that's why
there's other reasons as well why cbd
isn't more
readily studied in universities but
clearly cost
time and complexity is one major factor
another major factor
is the fact that
because the fda says cbd is a drug
not a supplement
and universities take federal funding
universities pretty much can only study
cbd under an investigational new drug
framework
and ind
and and clinical trials under ind
guidelines versus clinical trials under
say supplement
guidelines are
have
dramatically higher
cost and complexity
and even the manufacturers of the
products have to come under a lot more
scrutiny and regulatory hurdles so
that's probably one of the main reasons
why there isn't more cbd research coming
out of university settings say in
america because all these things have to
proceed under this very slow and
expensive ind investigational new drug
research framework and it's not the
university's fault they take federal
funding when you take federal funding
you have to follow these federal
guidelines very strictly
all right so in
conclusion what we're saying from the
study is that
you know comparable populations and
what's nice again is we had
a pretty diverse mix of individuals
that comprom comparable populations
taking similar cbd products
can experience significant improvements
in their well-being their anxiety their
sleep quality and their pain in just
under four weeks
and often with the improvements
dramatic improvements happening even in
the first week
the findings in the study also suggest
what we've known already from other
studies that cbd generally has a
favorable safety profile participants
reported few adverse events and they
were generally mild
most common ones being
gastrointestinal related
and the last thing is
looking at the products in our studies
it appears that the health outcomes and
the effects might be contingent upon the
amount of cbd per serving and
paradoxically
more cbd per serving is not necessarily
better
and
whereas when we looked at for example
the spectrum broad isolate
and full we didn't necessarily find
any significant difference when we
grouped products that way
now on the cbd
serving side there's some interesting
animal studies
and
a handful of human studies that have
also
shown that more cbd is not necessarily
better
that there is a moderate dose of cbd
that has better
effects than either a high dose
or a low dose
and so
that this has been demonstrated again in
both mostly animal studies but there's
also a handful of human studies that
have played with different doses and
found that the optimal effectiveness
actually came from an intermediate or
not intermediate dose from an absolute
term but came from a
dose that was in the middle of several
doses that they were exploring
so with that we will
open it up to questions
great
thank you dr chen for your informative
presentation and we will now start the q
a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started
our first question is how and when do
you think regulation on cbd will change
so
there have been
several attempts in congress to actually
pass a law
that would
make cbd a dietary supplement and would
subject it to the same regulations as
all
dietary supplements and so
these proposed bills in the past have
gotten bipartisan support
in fact
the
push for hemp legalization was actually
driven
predominantly
by
republican
uh politicians
who
had a lot of agricultural constituents
who wanted a new cash crop
that wasn't tobacco that wasn't corn and
hemp is much more valuable as a cash
crop if you can actually use the
cannabinoids from it if you just grow it
for fiber or seed it's it's worth
a tiny fraction than if you can grow it
for cannabinoids so i think there are
there is there is bipartisan support as
well
for
regulation that will clarify and make
cbd
a supplement
because
the retailers want it consumers want it
and even the farmers want it
as well so i wouldn't be surprised if
it's going to take it's going to be a
congressional act that's going to
add clarity and full legality to the use
of cbd as a supplement i don't think
it's going to be the fda suddenly
changing
its stance
and as for when that'll happen
you know the best you know there's a
saying that's like never predict the
future if you don't want to be wrong
so uh as for when it'll happen who knows
man i think
uh they were trying to get another bill
introduced this year but it sounds like
there's just some other more pressing
concerns right now in congress so it
might not might still be years before we
get any clear
clarity on the eye on the issue
all right thank you for that
another question we have is what are the
cbd dosages that were associated with
greater chances for achieving clinically
meaningful reductions in symptoms
right so
and
i i need to go back and take a look
at the data set but if you see let's see
if i can jump to it
so if you look at
it was actually the the doses below 15
milligrams that
were often outperforming the higher
doses and again
dose is not the end-all be-all
because these products differ in other
attributes as well now if all the
products were the same they were all
full spectrum gummies that just differed
in dose then you could say oh
interesting like here's what the the
dose showed but in this case the
products differed in a lot of areas but
as far as we can tell when we just
looked at dose setting aside the other
attributes
we found that you know products with
less than 15 milligrams per serving
were
often outperforming the products at
higher ones and we had products in the
study that had servings of
you know over 25 milligrams over 50 all
the way approaching
100 but again this is just on average
and it wasn't all the time that the
lower doses are performed the higher
doses
now
what's interesting is if you look at the
clinical trials that have been done on
cbd showing benefits for epilepsy
schizophrenia addiction
and social anxiety for example
they were testing doses
hundreds of milligrams a day all the way
up to a thousand or in excess of a
thousand milligrams a day
the published literature you know
blinded randomized controlled clinical
trials on cbd
has so so so rarely studied less than
you know 200
milligrams and has pretty much not
studied
2035 you know all these other values
so there is a big
gap in the literature
and but again looking at some of the
animal studies and some of the human
studies there's this notion that hey
more cbd might not necessarily be
better
and it's not just cbd this is not an
uncommon phenomenon pharmacology
where in the in the dosage window there
sometimes is a
moderate dose that's actually most
optimal
thank you for that
and our next question is what evidence
is there for a so-called entourage
effect
right so
it primarily comes from
animal studies
where
they would give the the mice
say pure cbd
versus a
temper cannabis extract that had a same
amount of cbd so the dose was the same
but that extract had all the other stuff
in the plant other terpenes other
cannabinoids of their vital compounds
and they found pretty distinct
differences in their effects and
outcomes so a few studies that come to
mind they looked at inflammation in rats
and they found that even when matched
for the same dose of cbd the full
spectrum the plant extract significantly
outperformed
a same dose of cbd when it was just cbd
by itself had much better
anti-inflammatory effect
also when looking at
studies in cancer cell lines again not
even animal but like a petri dish
studies a huge caveat but they would
take for instance pure thc
and expose the cells in the tumor cells
in the petri dish to the pure thc
and then they would expose
the tumor cells to a cannabis extract
that had the same amount of thc but
again had a bunch of other stuff in it
and the cannabis extract had
significantly better anti-cancer
activity the pure thc was able to kill a
certain percentage of the cancer cells
but the cannabis extract was able to
kill significantly more
and so
the real question
for this the so-called entourage effect
first off you know is it present in
humans and also
you know there's so many different
types of cannabis and they're grown so
differently
it's
even if this turns out to be true it's
not going to be true
all the time if that makes any sense
because every
extract of cannabis is a completely
different
assortment of
dozens if not hundreds of physically
active
compounds
and so there's been some work by
daddy marie out of israel where he took
a cannabis extract
and then sequentially
purified it more and more and more and
each time he did a round of purification
he would expose in this case again with
cancer cells he'd expose cancer cells to
a extract that was getting increasingly
purified
until he found that the effects started
to change then he would know oh well
these were the
you know five compounds that were
purified out and the effects changed
maybe one of those five was a key
constituent so a big question for the
entourage effect is do you need hundreds
do you need dozens do you need is it
like three key compounds
in the cannabis plant that will
effectively create the effect that the
whole extract
will create and if you look at dede's
work at least when it comes to cancer
cell lines it looks like the answer is
somewhere between like
two and
eight
two to eight
ingredients
are critical and can effectively
approximate the entire plant
extract but again human studies are
still pretty lacking right now aside
from this
anecdotal observation that pure thc has
been fda approved
for
you know almost 40 years yet no one
really uses it everyone gravitates
towards medical cannabis you know
visit both physicians and patients so
thank you for that response and then we
can try to wrap up with this last
question i don't know if there'll be a
set answer but somebody was curious if
there was a reason the steady duration
wasn't a little bit longer
sure yeah so part of the reason
for the study duration was just the the
speed with which we wanted to launch and
complete the study and get data out
there
you know when we
launched the study our company was only
a few months old so we launched the
study
last summer and it was done before
christmas
so you know pretty unprecedented this
this is a study that should have taken
you know whatever five years we got it
done in six months
so part of that was we kept the study
duration short so that we could actually
finish the study quicker and get the
results back to
the brands in the study and get the
results back to society faster
furthermore we had a suspicion that
based on some prior preliminary studies
we've done
that the effects would happen in the
first couple weeks and then we kind of
plateau off so we could have done a
longer study i don't think there would
have been that much of a difference
between say day 30 and day 60 like i
don't think i don't think their pain
would have gotten that much better or
worse beyond how it already changed in
the first 30 days
but certainly there is a role for longer
term
studies and and what the fda is asking
for is longer term studies where they
specifically get to track
liver function
um
but again a long-term study on a lot of
people
tracking liver function it's super super
expensive right now no one's really
stepped up to
pay for that especially if that would be
a study done on non-prescription
products that you can't really patent
and monopolize the same way that you can
with a pharma product so that's why
there's a lot more safety data on
epidiolex right the fda approved cbd
product
than
you know these commercial products
because
the the there really isn't these
companies don't have the budgets
to pay for you know multi-million dollar
long-term safety studies unfortunately
it's not it's not their fault it's just
that type of research is really
expensive
that makes sense thank you for your
insight
um thank you overall dr chen for your
informative presentation
for your time today and your important
research and before we'd go i'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitting during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until march 23 2024 and lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with any
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
thank you again until next time goodbye
thanks for having me bye
you